Chào lời phòng vấn Fox News đã phía viên Mỹ về Trung Đông's triệu quyết khóc đường giả nhé lên.
Yván có thể chỉ còn cách khả năng sản xuất tình liệu chỉ tà bong, ở cấp độ của cưng nghiệp khoảng 1 ton.
Đông thơ tệnh báo để là dự nhiên quyết quyền quyền nghiệp đối với anh điên khu vực.
Ông tại khẳng định cảm kết của tổng thống Mi đô nên trăm, về nguyên tác không làm sao u ra đi, trong bất kỳ thời thần tương lây nào với tệnh ràn,
nhấn mạnh các lần zinh đạo đã đều đặt xa só sản.
Theo các nguồn tình từ chính quyền Mỹ, Washington đang giả tăng sát xa của sự và chuẩn bị các tịch bản,
nếu các thẳng theo thang, cho mối cảnh đăng phát hình nhân dưới bên bản tiếp diễn,
theo lần một quan chức như một phần của chính sĩ có thể xa.
Washington có thể tiến hành tức của tấn công và cơ sở nhắn nước và anh điện quyền ràn,
chưa không chỉ tiến thơ sở hạ tăng hành nhân, các quan chức này cũng nhận định mất kỳ chính sĩ của sự năng nhằm bởi răng,
có thể giắn tựa cho đỏ đáp trẻ có lại vàng nguy cơ sức độ giống hơn.
về phía Iran ngoài trường á bác sỡ trí khẳng định, chứ gian nhân của nước này mang của bếc ngoà bình và không chứ nhận từ bảo gần đậu làm giấu ra đi.
Đồng thời tuyên bố, tây răng sẵn chức cả con đường ngoại sao và sưng anh đối đau nước cần thiết.
Sông sọng về đó hạ bên và tăng tức tục cân lực lượng lối hạ đạm phát phát hạp nhân kể tôi đợt không kích làm ngoái.